this video is an ad for Dragon veil
Michael mark dude I have found it the
best mobile app ever seriously dude you
know oh wait shut up I've already found
a better one you're gonna love this I'm
glad you called because I need you to
send me gifts oh yeah okay
really Bob Bob hey Bob I need gifts not
not real gifts but in getting gifts an
app I thought please wait I am in the
middle of something with mark here okay
highway Oh mark good I need your help
too
I need you to be my friend just this
once I need you both let me help me out
please
please wait no wait I'm not joining
whatever crap game you're playing if you
want gifts you need to play dragon veil
with me mark come on all right listen up
you guys I need you to shut your
collective face holes right now and
listen I've got this great game called
dragon veil and I need you to download
it right no no no I'm tired of being
interrupted just get the game be my
friend and give me gifts that's what
friendship is all about anyway
so it's fall in line and if you don't I
will shove my honey foot up your mother
loving behind your crazy boys yeah all
right thank you love you thank thank you
love you all right love you bye
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Dragon River now this
video was supposed to come out before
the charity livestream that we just did
and for good reason
Bob and Wade's videos have already been
posted I'll put links to those in the
and thanks to them and them joining me
on this paid promotion for Dragon Vail I
will be able to donate $10,000 to Toys
for Tots which is the charity that we
raise money for in this past event you
can find the confirmation and proof of
that donation down in the description as
well so this game if you don't know
about it it's kind of like a city
building game that you've played on
mobile before probably but it's
different you're trying to build a
dragon Park and you're trying to breed
and grow dragons and if you're wondering
about breeding I'm absolutely 100% sure
about that because you get a place
called a breeding cave and I'm not gonna
go into too many details about this cave
because frankly they don't go into too
many details either it says this is the
place where the magic happens
wink seriously we're just not sure how
it works we just know that this is where
dragons come from upgrade the breeding
cave decreases about the time it takes
to breed by 20% you know they put in
some scented candles and some mood
lighting and some smooth jazz playing on
in the background for whatever magic is
happening there and if that wasn't
enough there's an even better thing
there's a cooperative breeding game and
I don't know if there's info about this
the cooperative breeding gave us a model
of Wizarding ingenuity that allows to
breeding caves to link magic working
across space and time with the help of
everybody in Dragon Vale the astronomer
know to plant a brought a piece of
falling star safely to rest he then did
what any self-respecting wizard would do
with an unknown material he did a
breathing cave no guard says it's fine
as long as we don't destroy the universe
you know I think it's fine to I'm all
I'm willing to allow this so I don't
pursue this is getting stuck in the game
but I find this game hilarious and
interesting nonetheless okay but that's
for another time we're gonna get back to
that in just a bit but first we need to
check in on our actual dragons which are
adorable and cute and right here and
this little guy he's adorable
but the developers gave me noodles and
Kaboodle's and um toodles of resources
so I'm gonna feed him until he grows up
into a big oh my god oh no you're
marginally less cute why can't you stay
cute happen to happen to happen to
happen to happen to happen to happen to
happen to happen to happen it oh that's
it
oh I guess cinders all grown up now so
we don't need to worry about that oh
[ __ ] I love hold up oh my god
that's the thing about this game every
time you level up a lot and every time
you level up it unlocks like 15
virgilian things which i guess is good
oh my god
got a what the hell wait I got celestial
habitat on the TAT first galaxy island
fourth galaxy island second galaxy
island second island third galaxy oh my
god alright cinder you go stomping
around that volcano don't wreck up the
place for anybody else also you get
these winners it's the winner themed
version it's the winner Jubilee which
means that there's a lot of winter
themed stuff and there's a snowman
walking around my my farm but I'm not
sure what that's all about anyway
alright hey do you want buffer god I
make this one ball sack oh it's above
Socko it's it's not bad in any way it's
possible alright alright boss time to
eat oh you're oh god you're way less
cute oh no oh no why do you have a ball
of the feeder head ball sack oh that's
your ball goes oh boy or a habitat
chrysalis habitat large cold habitat
large Earth habitat meridiem a debt
monolith habitat rainbow habitat
snowflake habitat spooky habitat twily
tower weather station blazing gale
dragon bog dragon chrysalis dragon decay
dragon delight dragon double rainbow
dragon Tuscan oh my god I can gun dragon
I see governor I can hire dragon - oh my
god oh oh I can just get the Fountain of
Youth oh who knew who knew is that
simple oh my god reading hints I need to
know about this the Breen
pair of Dragons must container - drama -
dragon and either a galaxy dragon or an
epic dragon the breeding pair all these
are the different types that I could
breed oh my how many are there oh my god
oh my there's so many oh there's so much
stuff to this game that's kind of cool
Rob um or bows you're gonna be you're
gonna be roughing the or below you can
be rub on the or because that's as many
that's many uh it's as many characters
as I'm allowed here and probably as much
freedom as I should have
now let's breed them I mean this is like
the crux of the game because to be able
to get all the different fairies since
the Dragons I imagine that you have to
breed them together so I'm gonna get
rubber more them with ball sack oh and
go for it
amazing amazing I was peering in through
the window and it was amazing magic
happened don't know what it was but
whatever it was it was amazing okay
wait where are they above where are they
above the dragon cave that doesn't make
sense what's not the magic I was
thinking about how can I speed this
along a little it'll add a breeder
breeder yay hey if dragons were alive in
real life I don't think I'd want to be a
breeder of dragons that sounds like an
incredibly dangerous occupation that
which I do not want to be around leave
that to the Harry Potter world's what
hybrid poison dragon that's that's
horrible hope you put that in there
Oh No why do you exist Oh God ooh what a
specimen just keep it at a distance yes
Oh God that's uh that's so sad it's so
hideously ugly if we keep it at a
distance okay you know what whatever
banging a judge who am I to judge nope
nope not any more handsome in fact it's
worse
it's much worse oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
god what do you have a crown that's cool
so that's another thing about this game
there are a lot of minigames and there's
a lot of stuff that you can do during
the game okay this is all part of the
winner do believe by the way so you're
supposed to get ice berries and you're
supposed to play these games and get
them for unique and excellent rewards
and this is what you got these are the
minigames oh god I'm not gonna be good
at this are my dear Freddie
Oh shooty shoot I'll shoot
well I sucks so anyway that's that's the
special event that's going on right now
so I will leave this advant there's a
lot more to explore throughout the game
and I've actually only scratched the
surface of it thank you everybody so
much for watching definitely check this
game out I'll put a link in the
description and also you can check out
the confirmation for the donation and
Bob and Wade's associating videos down
in the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
buh-bye